[Music]
hey guys in this video I'm bringing you
all the major leagues and spoilers that
have been confirmed to happen in the
final season now game turns historically
leaks are a common problem onset of
gaming turns a head of season 7 if you
knew where to look you could find pretty
much the whole story laid out for you it
B has done a better for season 8 with
only a very few events being leaked
which is impressive considering the
scaled production this time around let's
start with the first major spoiler we
know about the next season now get in
terms the battle from interval and its
outcome after seven seasons the nat king
has finally breached the wall and is
marching his army south if you've been
following a meter on season a new
assembly for us you know there's a big
battle set to take place in season 8 and
it's been confirmed to take place in the
third episode of the final season by the
actor who plays the night king of
Lattimer verdict
even though VFL will not be the first
castle to get destroy in his path he
will arrive over there by the 3rd
episode which is when this epic battle
for Winterfell begins for declared the
newest lead during a fan convention in
Hungary he said and spoiled in the 3rd
episode of the last season there's a
battle that creators intended to be a
historic moment in television almost the
full episode will be about the battle it
will take about one hour verdict states
that they filmed this battle for three
months in the rain and the rain outdoors
and then for another month in a huge
studio which makes this far and away the
most labor intensive battle sequence in
the show's history and therefore in the
history of TV you can tell you that
there will be no shortage of surprises
in season 8 fairly continues there will
be a lot of dragons the night king will
return and in the season the biggest
battle for the tournament will be
completed Entertainment Weekly's cover
story from a few months back gave us an
inside look into the final game of
Thrones season through the eyes of James
Hebert the shaping up to be what
probably almost certainly is the longest
consecutive battle sequence in cinema
history
Hebert said and continued with they work
to try and find other ones out there
like the one in the two towers in the
Lords of the Rings which is about 40
minutes and in the movie 13 assassins
which was also around 40 minutes this is
going to be longer than 40 minutes it's
pretty nuts HBO has also gone all-in on
sets vs. need building the venom files
set to make it as close to real castle
as possible according to Heber the crew
was up to the challenge the mess of
expanding the Winterfell set
around point a camera at any direction
and shows more min of l1 of directors
pointing out that even a big-budget
Marvel or Star Wars movie they usually
only build what the actors are gonna
stand directly in front of and fill in
the rest with green screen but for this
set and a few others as well they built
it as 360-degree set so you don't have
to fill it with special effects you
don't have to favor one particular angle
you can have cameras follow people
around you can do unusual angles and
come up with different things on the day
of shooting so there laughs a lot more
creativity and it helps the actors no
acting required they're running around
these sets fighting with fake blood and
snow snow flying everywhere torches
burning fires and smoke it feels like
you're right there to film the Battle of
Winterfell
HBO built an enormous green screen in
order to bring their vision of an epic
battle to life so who was gathered there
for this week's long shoot first we got
the unsullied and the unsullied are not
the only people from Essos who are part
of the Battle of Winterfell
there are also the Trekkie riders
finally there's also shot that we think
is a Norton army and also there's a
trebuchet and said multiple people will
build flaming swords in the battle
against the dead but of all the
characters we know beric Dondarrion is
the one most closely associated with the
flaming sword seems like god ariana
shared a trick with a few people go so
have a fair amount of screen time and
will most definitely fight at this
battle the last time we saw ghost jon
snow's terrible he was raising his head
of the floor as his master was
resurrected from the dead since I
mentioned him once in season seven but
he never actually showed up on screen
there was actually ghosting written for
season seven but it got cut that is way
too much time to go without sight of
Jon's most consistent companion but
according to special effects supervisor
Joe Bauer that's all about to change
or you'll seem again Bauer told The
Huffington Post he has a fair amount of
screen time in season 8 he does show up
this battle is directed by Miguel
suppose Nick the guy behind some of the
best episodes of Game of Thrones
Leichhardt home in some winter and
battle the bastards
talking about this huge battle from
interval it's brutal said star peter
dinklage tyrion lanister it makes the
Battle of the Basterds look like a theme
park writing earlier about this historic
sequence James Hebert called it
wall-to-wall action and detail how he
jumps between stories of several
different characters but we also know
for a fact is that winter will not fall
at Winterfell this battle will be a huge
defeat for the living men Errol is on
fire the night king has won as you might
expect this battle will leave many dead
check out this image of corpses strewn
across the ground outside the Man Who
Fell set the money glass we can see what
looks like a feel strewn with the bodies
to the left of the castle including some
that look like horses
Mima we also have images of a pile of
body part props outside a castle and a
blood left on the castle walls as it
money glass the grounded mag Ramon
quarry was littered with corpses unlike
an money glass someone was able to get
up close and personal with the bodies
there are all kinds of corpses the most
surprising corpses were the ones bearing
the Kraken sigil of house Greyjoy they
don't expect the graduates to be part of
this battle but if they own already
saved yar by episode 3 then I don't see
where as they would be however it could
also be that your surprise attack
Winterfell with the golden company
either before or after the night he
attacked it anyway this is more in line
with what I was expecting this skeletal
corpses could be the bodies so White's
or they could be people flesh fried by
dragon fire next stop corpse blobs HBO
likely spread these things all over the
battlefield and covers them in some snow
from distance they look like this squid
corpses rather than a bunch of bodies
affixed one plate in this stays the miss
frost the direwolf marker over as well
as the marker for Danis and solid forces
but unfortunately the northern arm Union
solid are not going to be the only
casualties for the limit it's confirmed
that most of the track you will fall as
well and then shortly after be brought
back to life by the white walkers to
basically act as their minions here you
can see the tricky whites riding on
horseback but we cannot say for a fact
although it's been hinted by the
official T's is the Dana veil at some
point burned former to track you
loyalists
here we can see that the tracking marker
being burned does it for share of Danny
burn you try a key that fell during the
battle from interval maybe after this
epic battle from Winterfell the net gain
will conquer the north and the living or
at least what's left of them will have
to retreat south and once again parley
with Cersei and urine which gets us to
another confirmed event Johnston will
return to King's Landing in episode 4 at
the end of season 7 Justin was carried
home to Winterfell he will not stay
there for the first time in the history
of the Sirius Star kit harington was
film shooting something in Dubrovnik
meaning that the king in the northeast
headed back to his landing at some point
in season 8 in this photo Harrington is
the Dubrovnik Smith Sara tower which is
part of the city boss there's also this
mysterious shot of Jon Snow being
escorted along the walls by a couple of
men in black
John inserts a meeting in Lane
let's move from the Meseta tower to
bokor fortress another impressive
structure on the dubrovnik city walls as
you can see a Lannister flag flies above
the fortress so what ever since soon
there takes place and Cersei still in
charge sir st. John's snow meet one on
one engines landing
well not exactly one on one it starts
there as the mountain and her Queen's
Guard by her side the final major
spoiler we know is taking place in the
final season of inferences the fall of
the capital King's Landing as some of
you may know for the final season of
Game of Thrones the production for the
very first time instead of filming is
landing scenes in Dubrovnik they decided
to make a huge King's Landing set in
Belfast and fill most of the scenes
there why did they build city buildings
to resemble the study they used for
King's Landing all these years instead
of filming at actual medieval towns as
they usually do
that's because game experience is not
allowed to burn cities to the ground as
construction for King's Landing set
focused on polishing the city walls
inside set streets a famous Dubrovnik
landmark has been faithfully reproduced
the crew built a whole city street at
one end there's the gate and that yard
the front of the red keep
in between there all manner of buildings
the most notable are surrogates in the
King's Landing dome however as you can
see in these leaked photos the set has
been modified to appear burned down the
huge bridge between the mallesh towers
the city gate has been obliterated in
the towers that once protected as he had
fallen the nut king has burned down a
huge portion of the capital including
his laning dome using his undead dragon
how can I know for sure that this is the
nikes doing
rather than a result of Cersei using
wild fire and burning down the entire
city even though burned King's Landing
set would seem to support the arrearage
search save burns down the entire city
the answer is no wildfire is not the
reason this part of insulating set is
being burned down is Dragon Fire how do
I know it's simply due to the fact that
show built a King's Landing set mainly
to do lipo techniques it means that some
parts of the capital will be burned down
by a dragon a dragon firing game Jones
is portrayed by live art techniques the
necking Schrag on that is responsible
for a huge portion of the capital being
burned down has also been spotted on
this King's Landing set yes dragons are
visual effects magic mostly however when
performers have to interact with Dragons
the number of methods are used to make
it work for example if Dany has to touch
the dragon's head any general head
shaped object will do such as this one
was used when the dragons for babies
this is nothing touching with Aaron's
head in
last season if actors had to actually
mount a dragon part of its spine has to
be physically recreated which is exactly
what its massive contraption on the
Atlantic stat is this massive
contraption being on this very same set
means that the night king will at some
point decide to land in King's Landing
perhaps in the final episode I've known
that Dragons will eventually fly over
King's Landing as brains saw it in his
vision of the future however I did not
quite expect it to be the night king
flying bazarian I expected it to be
Danny riding dragon perhaps it will be
both whichever dragon shows up and
whoever writes that Cersei will be ready
Qyburn Esme knew scorpion ballista for a
screen as seen in this leaked photo from
King's Landing set anyways it's not only
the Dragons who are shoving up at the
capital then his armies are coming as
well then solid in the track he also
visit King's Landing or at least a
little of them so right Battle of
Winterfell here you can see the
unsullied and what's left of the Trekkie
marching towards King's Landing gates
Cersei probably intends to use wildfire
and burn the entire King's Landing to
the ground once the living and the dead
start fighting in Sadr City and that
they get rid of all our enemies it's
possible that by this point Cersei Danny
and Jon Snow have teamed up and they're
fighting the white walkers together but
it's just as likely that Cersei won't
see the reason and then he has commanded
her armies to saw the city walls so
basically just arrives in episode 4 the
capital and meet Cersei
some time later Dana's armies come as
well and a dragon flies above King's
Landing
in a dragon or even dragons slain there
as well the capital is then burned down
in conclusion we know for major spoilers
about the final season no game Jones
number one epic Battle of Winterfell in
episode 3 deny convince Winterfell is on
fire many die number two ghost is back
number three Johnston goes back to the
capital powerless it serves say in
Episode four number four King's Landing
is burned down that's pretty much all
the major leagues and spoilers that have
been confirmed to happen in the final
season on game intros hopefully the
upcoming trailers will give us something
more and as always I hope you guys
enjoyed this video if you did please
make sure to subscribe to our Channel
and I hope to see you in the next one
peace